hey guys Chris here for the process and
we're going to be talking to min today
in episode 2 of the typography episode
of continuation of where we left off
last time I'm a little rusty so let's
see what happens
[Music]
hey Minh hey I want to go over a layout
for the future magazine you know people
in watching the episode now we're at
almost seventy thousand views so I think
we're doing something interesting here
and a little side note here why are we
doing this magazine I didn't provide any
context to our audience for as to what
we're doing and well I had this idea of
launching a magazine that would be kind
of a hybrid between how magazine and
Fast Company a place where you would
find out about a design but through the
lens of business and how design can
impact businesses and so men's been
helping me design the cover and the
spreads and all that kind of stuff and
she's had to work with just content that
she's scraped together and it's just a
template for content to come and we're
hoping that sometime in the first the
second quarter this year we'll actually
release a physical copy old-school media
printed version newspaper of what we're
talking about last time we were talking
to men I asked her to go deep and she's
come back and this little super resolve
now this looks really tight to me in
case you guys are wondering this is the
front and the back cover of the
newspaper these little hash marks on the
top and bottom delineate the fold so
this is a full wraparound design and I
really like how you're thinking about
the cover not so much as a
two-dimensional plane but almost a three
dimensional plane so I'm gonna hold up a
piece of paper here right so if I cover
up this part you'll see these elements
are the ones that make it over okay so
you're gonna see a little strip of that
okay so it looks like right now you've
really resolved the future logo and I
like that it's all lowercase Ventura and
in case people are wondering why they
would use for Torah and the name of the
company's future a few Torah think about
it you guys it's a it's I'd look for
those kind of happy coincidences that
you can make them happened and we try to
do that and she's doing a very simple
two color design it's black and yellow
to try to keep it a little more
economical for us to print and so
there's a lot you can do with daring the
tones doing screams of black and also
mixing black and yellow together
so here you can see men doing a yellow
overprint on the black and that creates
this kind of third shade of color and
once you get into print design these are
things and tricks that you can apply so
overall a really beautiful layout maybe
one thing that I don't love right now is
seeing a hard cutoff edge with just a
little remnants of type there but this
looks very resolved the futures first
core great okay so you're also putting
the table of contents right on the cover
right that's interesting approach okay
so I'm I think we need some space in the
back for maybe sponsors or advertising
that's a premium spot right there so I
think we need to save some space I also
like that you integrated QR code right
here and that way people can scan that
so we're doing this play between
traditional media like news and news
print and print and doing digital so if
you scan this and it'll take you to some
other thing maybe it'll take you an
article or take you to our website where
you can dive deeper and have richer
media experience I think that's pretty
cool all right what else you got so
there's a three color no that's still
two colors this is another way that you
guys can get more bang for your buck and
a two color design where she's using
dark blue and a yellow and you can mix
that two because yellow and blue make
green back from primary school right and
ignore the black so that's another way
you can do something like that alright
skip um so this is what the cover looks
like so you guys know before when I was
talking about this that having that cut
off like this it makes a really awkward
shape and you want something a little
bit more organic because that looks
really jarring to me and you can't beat
it anyways
okay other than that the layout looks
really good here so this is an interior
spread here
page two and three the future is not the
past okay
really beautiful typography oh so now
you've moved the table of contents on
the inside I also like how you took the
blocks of color and ran it right to the
edge of the type and a cap height line I
think that's pretty cool it's creating
some visual tension right there I like
how you've done an over print of a
typography here so that
the blockiness of the photographs get
broken up by the organic shape of the
topography it's a little bit hard to
read but like it and we'd have to look
at that I'm noticing a little problem
here you have a nice yellow shape here
in here but I noticed that contents the
base line is a little bit off like if we
were to zoom in on that
can you zoom in on that you see you guys
you'll see right here the baseline of
the type the word content should sit on
that yellow edge and that would be
really cool another thing you can do if
it were to sit on that base line is you
make the type white so you have some
figure-ground ambiguity like what's in
front and what's in back so if this type
were white put on top of the yellow
block it would create this thing where
I'm not sure if it's yellow sitting on
white or white sitting on yellow and
that's kind of always a nice Gestalt
thing to play around with you guys can
look up that word just all to me or
it'll probably put a graphic up here you
guys to see that this is do you have a
grid system usually this is where you
call them grid here what you do it looks
like a three column grid right I can see
one two three yeah three column grid
with the gutter in the middle and I like
these really sharp edges that she's
using here it's easy for me to find that
my my it's a spot where to read you're
also indenting here I'm not a fan of
indentation but that works you can see
it the eyes gonna scan along and then
it's going to see a little indent and
it's gonna pick it up but visually it's
just not as nice to me it's just doing
carriage return and then doing a hard
return and then just keeping it sharp
left corner but I like the overlapping
and with not using too many tricks using
a bold lead-in sentence it gives a lot
of variety in here and then I like the
pool quote and using a little bit of
yellow to draw your eye in there I think
that's quite nice and she's also using
hanging punctuation you guys don't know
about hanging punctuation it's when the
quotes get pulled outside of the left
margin that way your type is lined up
really beautifully nice I see some
repeating motifs it's important that
when you're doing a layout like this for
a magazine like ours or a newspaper
since it's not that deep to have some
kind of graphic consistency across like
how we use yellow as
only as a variation to design but it's
actually letting us know that these are
call-outs it's highlighting things kind
of like the way you would do with a
highlight marker so I like you blocking
these parts out and it's nice and I also
like using the colors integrated and
it's very simple graphic I'm wondering
to hear if by boxing it off in this
little thin yellow line that it might be
better just to let this thing be a
little bit more organic and like break
out of the box so in InDesign we're
always trying to push against like
opposites in the contrast where you have
something that's smooth and then you
have something that's rough so you have
a lot of blocky elements it becomes a
very repetitive try to open up the
design and have more curvilinear forms
or organic shapes and I think the
variety makes the layout much more
interesting and also when you're using a
light color like yellow on white try to
make the lines thick enough so you can
see you can see that on a contrast level
this is it when you goes to print we
might not be able to see it as clearly
so just be mindful that I also like how
you created white shapes in here to push
the type out but to and then being able
to feature a boat in there and she's
using the kind of triangular motif and
you can see that throughout I assume
this is the author right so something
that we're doing is we're gonna be
calling different contributors to submit
ideas for the magazine and our exchange
there is if we feature your article we
want to give a shout-out to you so this
is a placeholder for potential artists
and some information about how to find
out more about them okay great good job
nice okay so here's an example where min
is letting it be more organic and
there's a shape here what I would
suggest here is to let the pencil break
the grid a little bit if you can have an
organic element like a let it flow
outside okay I think that would be nice
and I also like now we've seen type
overlaying on images but type over type
this works really well the reason why it
works is this is really big and bold and
it's a chunky amount and it's light
yellow color while you have the finer
body copy in black and to sitting on top
of each other make for a really nice
combination and here I like how men
instead of just doing one box for the
photo how she cropped it and put into
three boxes I think it would be cool if
you are gonna crop it and put into three
boxes do more Dave David Hockney ask
anything where you you make some of the
images bigger and smaller so that
there's a little bit more of an offset
okay cool
really great layouts very sharp you guys
can appreciate that right okay this
bothers me a little bit here because we
have the text and then we have it kind
of a tangency to the top of the box
feels a little bit off to me whenever
you have two elements that are close to
each other it should be like a right on
top or should be farther apart so it's
the ones in the middle it's kind of like
a no-man's land that's where you want to
push and break it out okay I like
everything about this page
beautiful big chunk type and this is a
DIN black din okayed ndin you guys
that's another one of our favorite
typefaces and an approved typeface if
you're looking at the typography manual
I love how there's so much negative
space and the contrast we talked about
just before having something really
large like this next is something very
tiny and delicate like this the two play
off each other really well so it's
really nice there and then in terms of
the illustration the only thing I don't
like about this as a sillas tration I
think that maybe though the money signs
on the cloud something about it feels
like not professional not not speaking
to business people the illustration
concept itself is nice how they were
like building something in the cloud but
just that throws me off a little bit
everything else is so sophisticated
this one throws me off okay ooh I like
this I like this a lot we've been
talking about repeating forms and motifs
and before we saw this little triangular
wedge more as an anchor for the author
and now means taking that as a shape and
using that instead of a traditional box
and breaking it up this kind of layout
is very hard to achieve in terms of
getting the harmony to work because you
have to have movement around the page
but you have to be able to do it so it
doesn't feel like it
and drawing your eye off so it almost
feels like maybe there's some kind of
golden means golden rectangle trying you
know square or something where it feels
like it's kind of drawing this in to
loop which is very nice we got some
widows here because the Internet's gonna
get mad at me if I don't mention that
it's kind of hard to avoid on a small
block of copy like this so that's when
you maybe work with the writer to add or
delete a few words so that this yeah it
did you don't end on a widow right
okay now you're using the duotone thing
right okay so we still have this okay
now you've added in a sample add block
here not quite a full-page ad this is
like a junior full-page ad or something
like that and now you're using the blue
and yellow and she's using a duotone
here so you're getting a lot more bang
for the buck there if you guys look at
that
I like how sometimes the blue is opaque
and sometimes maybe there's an
opportunity for you to make the blue
over and over print so the blue and the
yellow are mixing together so those are
all like leads a little tricky printing
things that you can do I see you've got
this and it's worked out this still bugs
me a little bit right and you put in the
barcode it's really interesting when you
put in the barcode and all the social
media almost like the legalese copy that
it makes the layout feel real like it
feels like you just pull this off the
newsstand right so again if I cover this
up you guys can see that having the
barcode having the price the date all
that kind of stuff to make something
feel really like if they existed and so
there's a tip for you there if you guys
are doing some spec projects and you
wanted to make it look more like it's
it's a commissioned piece include some
of those details because those details
signify to us on a subconscious level
that it must be real now this is a
full-color ad here and I'm wondering now
our budgets gonna go through the roof
right so you're adding different colors
so we have to kind of figure out how to
do that now maybe we reserved the cover
and in the back for a full color and we
could spend money on that I don't know
and you can see the differences go up
one where she's mixing the duotone print
and you can do this in Photoshop by
selecting two PMS colors or go down
where this is just a monotone
it's just using blue instead of printing
with black it uses this dark blue okay
and this is just the same layout right
just using the two tones okay great so
let's just scan through this go ahead oh
look at that you guys there's something
different this is new right to me to buy
I having these duo tones in here really
add a lot of pop and value because for
before it's very flat and graphic so
it's nice to have a combination of both
we've talked about the contrast in point
sizes in in weight or texture and now we
have contrasting image or illustration
styles and this is pretty cool so men
went away from the thin yellow box and
it's almost the same graphic as before
except for now she's using bold or not
bold but other said a little mistake
there there's a light yellow line but
anyways and now the illustration breaks
outside and you can see it it feels a
lot more dynamic and it breaks it here
and here and that's really cool you
gotta take a look at this take a look at
that Erin can you tell like one feels
more expensive than the other right and
it's just by using duotone just being
kind of having mastery over the process
of printing helps you to kind of bring
in new concepts or ideas to kind of push
your budget a little bit in terms of
achieving a perceived value increase
even though it's not really okay that's
really nice okay nice this also looks
much better and duotone print this could
be like a beautiful annual report or
something
and I also like how you use the
triangles so it's almost like Minh has
three or four ingredients like when you
watch chopped that reality show on the
Food Network how you you have a mystery
basket and you pull out salt Twinkies
and sardines like what are you gonna do
with those three things you don't know
but here min is taking one element one
ingredient like say sardines and she's
figured out like how to make a soup out
of how to make a salad how to make a
sandwich how to make a main course and
an appetizer
I don't want ingredient that ingredient
right now is this triangular shape so
the triangular shape is an anchor for
the author's bio
or his contact information the
triangular shape is a mask to hold as a
container photography and illustration
the triangle is also used as a way for
your eye to find the different points oh
those little triangles and they're all
treated a little bit differently right
so one has a circle over it one has a
duotone image one is just small and it
points right to where the points begin
Minh is trying a bunch of different ways
to present the author so I know that
people on the internet had remarks like
Wow after the first a second idea I'm
stuck and mins ability to kind of just
take one thing and play and play and
play it allows us to look at kind of
almost every option that you can
conceive of and this shows men's ability
or her elasticity and her creativity to
try lots of different things they're all
appropriate they all look really good
I'm not sure I have one favorite over
another do you yeah that one looks
really good and that's the one you want
to be using right but it's good to see
all the exploration oh and here's a
mock-up okay
so we have the two up grid have we
resolved what the covers gonna look like
yet it's still working progress all
right we're gonna release this thing in
first or second quarter so here we're
using three colors blue and the yellow
and you can see now we picked a much
more vibrant blue and yellow do you know
why we picked the blue in the yellow man
why do we pick that the vibrancy oh yeah
something that really pops it's almost
like fluorescent it's a really rich deep
saturated blue and a really vibrant
yellow okay what else is down there so
that's a different angle of it now
did you print this out and and make
something and photograph it
oh you know Photoshop lock up okay so
let me address something to our audience
okay
people always wondering like are mockups
cheating like should we use them lock up
isn't that just because everybody else
has the same mock up and you can use
that and I think that's for me it's
gonna get controversial in about two
seconds I think that's just insecurity
I'm just gonna call it out we use lots
of tools we use any and every tool and
the thing that's important to me is the
exploration and the realization if your
idea not necessary like if you went on
to this to the store and bought the
paper and print it out and you cut it up
and then did all this stuff in order the
paper from French paper company to print
it out what for let's just say the
layouts bad I would rather have men do
those kind of explorations with how to
treat the authors and come up with 12
layouts then for her to sit there and
mock this thing up for real and print it
out there's a time and place for that
this is not the time or the place and
once you get into the professional
working space you'll realize a person
who can produce multiple high-quality
iterations of a design over another
person is going to be exponentially more
valuable this is cool that's what I want
to see so Minh spent 10 minutes found
the right mock-up and she has he still
used an editorial I she's not gonna just
pick an ugly one it was on a freebie
background or whatever else that's back
there just a simple gray seamless psyche
and then to drop this in and it's just
done what is this oh this is the
InDesign the latest latest version okay
so if you guys want to know what program
she's using she could have used either
Adobe Illustrator or Adobe InDesign and
for doing multiple page layouts and
spreads and masters it's a lot easier to
do it in InDesign so remember how I was
talking about this block it's al
uncomfortable for me so she's trying
lots of different things here I'm not
sure a client's gonna want us to facing
their ad by having the type bleed over
that's just unfortunate reality we had
to deal with okay freeze right there
alright so you can see now min has taken
the photograph and done they Hockney
treatment and scaled them a little
differently creates a little more visual
interest
oh here's min trying to fix this part
here they're not nefeli resolve maybe
that's not a great idea maybe we need an
okay
drawing something that can sit on top
without a box on it cool all right
thanks very much
man and I think we'll hopefully have
satisfied the need for typography and
didn't see more of what min is done
sorry it's taking us so long to get this
episode out to you guys leave your
comments below we'll be checking it out
thanks a lot I'm Chris and this is the
process